[تصفيق]
كان نفسي بحفله كان نفسي بفرح عرس كان
نفسي اعزم اكون انا واصحابي انا وقرايبي
انا واولاد عمي انا
والحته وزي اي واحد والحمد لله يعني ولاد
عمي اللي كنت ها بتنجد فيهم انه سندي انه
يقفوا معايا عننا 20 شاهدين ولاد يا عمي
زي ما انت شايف الخيمه مرجع ترجيع والحمد
لله يعني ود الحلال يعني اللي بيجي من
الله ما بدناش نقول لا وين في خيمه وعند
الحدود ولا عمرنا كنا نحلم بس انا لما
شفته تصاوب الله نجاه من الموت قلنا يعني
بدنا نيجي على حالنا شويه صح احنا مش
مستعجلين على الجيزه بس انه حقه انه يفرح
الثاني حطينا ايدنا في ايده وتكتف وان شاء
الله الله يتمم فرحهم على خير هنيهم ويكتب
لهم حياه زوجيه سعيده وهذا حالنا في غزه
وعننا شهداء وعننا جرحى يعني قد ما بده
يفرح الواحد الفرحه بتكون
مكسوره